好 在亮縮的時候
有時候叫做黎明前的黑暗
因為大家都知道
第四季到明年
其實又會重新展開一段的行情
這個歷年的漲率都非常高
王伯已經獨家幫我們做好了研究了
到底什麼東西今年已經成長了
明年會成長更多
這個就很重要了
你認為CPU跟設備
下個禮拜
其實除了中秋節
神山也要開技術論壇
對 我覺得是很有機會
因為不管是那個朱老師咬
或者是婉婷咬
其實大部分都是
整個操作可能你還是要回歸所謂基本面
那當然朱老師在技術面上
我提醒大家
你可能要注意說
有哪些什麼
有哪些是剛勾上來的
形態好的
對對對
那除了所謂的FED升息之外
那當然野外的BOSS就是
Enthopic
是
那個執行長
好
那當然我去查一下
那個Enthopic的那個大股東
那個谷歌
亞馬遜
還有微軟 還有我們的
輝達 大股東
對 然後那個老黃都講話了
老黃講說
老黃是認為說
速度跟安全可以兼顧
所以我的看法是說
如果你要去AI安全
搞不好什麼
搞不好你用AI來製AI
所以你可能要更多的設備
跟算力的提升
所以我認為
我認為如果說
野外BOSS已經被什麼
被大股東給壓制了
對嘛
那當然我們就要看
所謂的聯準會
接下來的表現
那至少啦
至少我們有提到說
根據過去的經驗
如果說那個升息的疑慮
恐慌越大的話
其實這些個股應該不會有表現
高科技股
對對
而且這些個股可能跌的時候
那個壓力很大
可是我們看喔
這個當然是資安的啦
資安的那個cross-cry是創高
創新高
可是問題來了
硬體的代表也創新高
所以我的看法是說
其實從這個角度來看
似乎啦似乎
有的股票回撤所謂
長天期均線之後
事物怎麼樣 事物慢慢的穩住
那如果這些是火種的話
那當然對台灣股票市場來講
就很好啦 就很好
那當然我們還是看一下
外資在台紫期的那個
好 今天結算後
對 他有減啦
整個減 他的未評商
剩下7.6萬的那個進空部位
這樣減了六七千口掉
對 減蠻多啦 減蠻多
所以大家都在想說
以前都8萬口的那個進空
大家都很緊張
那現在是不是慢慢的想說
剛才那個PCB女王說
我要來幫你教 你知道嗎
那個光輝十月你知道
然後可能稍微減一下
那我覺得散戶也怎麼樣
也很謹慎
所以你可以發覺說
好像怎麼拉上來的時候
它的那個什麼
多空比有稍微降下來
所以我覺得這對台股來講是好的
只是說現在大家可能想說成交量
其實成交量要補不難嘛
對不對 那個
信心回來就回來了
那當然這個我覺得高盛
高盛上修光模組需求
我覺得有點在回應
那個台積電的技術副總
因為之前在國際半導體展的時候
他說滲透率會來到50%
50 2027年
那時候我們還討論說
怎麼算的啦
對 怎麼算的啊
那時候我們看那個滲透率
今年大概就5%嘛
10倍
所以我覺得
我覺得可能
不管是台積電這一部分
或者是高盛
可能認為良率跟產能都開出來
其實高盛這邊報告其實寫得很清楚
所以我的看法是說
不管是所謂的那個2026 2027
基本上是成長
而且從800G 1.6T
甚至還跟你講說
上全聯亞全新
他還是看好
所以以目前看來
以目前看來我覺得說
其實CPU這一塊
我們還是要特別留意而且不是沒有跌這次剛好都有跌下來剛好這段時間有修正了這裡我們就來看一下今天紅通通的一片好 今天歡迎鼓舞除了可能剛剛講的高盛
或者是下禮拜的台資電技術論壇
其實因為焊測很多人沒抽到
沒抽到錢可能就回到市場上
我有一個朋友抽到好開心
真的假的
我第一次聽到有人抽到
好 那當然我們還是分成
那個老舊的CPO跟新CPO
其實我認為其實
股票有的都整理的差不多
特別是你看那個大力光跟玉金光之前
我們在這邊追蹤的時候
長了一大段
然後後來兩個機構法人
來做一個所謂比較負面的看法
那我是覺得
壓下來之後搞不好怎麼
搞不好機會又來了
其實如果我們只是一看
玉金光很特別
外資在買 投信在買
400張大戶也在買
對對對
所以今天玉金光就一馬當煙衝上去
其實有時候我就覺得說
像大摩這篇報告我就蠻疑惑的
怎麼說
什麼叫做降頻 然後調升目標價
好 對 確實是如此
降頻等 可是目標價提升
那代表他之前看錯
好 但目標價沒有比他限價高
對 對 對
代表他之前看錯嘛
然後這一次他怎麼樣
他想要認錯 但是也很不甘願
我不問為什麼要降頻調高目標
其實我想了半天啊
但是搞不懂他為什麼要這樣寫
他就那個認錯
然後不要不甘願不是很好嘛
但是這一次啦
這次如果我們仔細看的話
其實投信在最近的動作
的確在CPU這部分比較少
對 所以CPU是有回檔的
對 是有回檔
但是在千張大幅或四百張
都有部分其實還是有在做一個琢磨
那我的看法是這樣
我看我們還是鎖定一些
低價或低位階的
然後呢 現在怎麼樣
現在我剛好聽到朱老師講
可能大盤在這邊還要稍微區間
是
對不對 等待光輝十月
所以中秋節前
我們就先區間
中秋節後 來嘎外資
嘎外資
對對對
好 那我們當然要繼續看
那這之前講的配亨
雖然這段也有回回不深
今天漲停板也
對 但是我還是覺得
因為他是從低檔上來
所以他還是一段一段說
最好是有回啦 有回你在進場
他應該沒有跌到你的防守價吧
沒有沒有沒有
好 其實上個禮拜
我們在談CPU
最有趣的一檔股票是哪一檔
你知道嗎 誰
聯軍
聯軍我記得那時候我說
聯軍回測季限可以買
小哥說什麼
小哥開布林
他說浪子回頭我們要賠
對對對
所以如果大家在上個禮拜
浪子回頭有賠的話
今天漲停板
其實今天漲停板
聯軍的價格是超越
那個我們上個禮拜講的點很多
我們賠他就不會賠錢
對對對
那另外就是光盛
其實這一波其實有上來
上來之後其實他也壓下來
對 他為什麼那麼的讓人有點難過
雖然他是從一千漲上也漲很多了
但很多人很希望他能夠像聯亞一樣衝
其實我覺得他是還有機會
而且其實有一些外資
有些當然是短線
但是基本上其實這種形態就是說
其實這一波的聯亞是衝很快
聯亞衝很快之後
其實大家回來看光盛
其實光盛就是什麼
就是這邊還有很多
很多壓力
就看有沒有辦法關關難過
現在只要貨源 料源拿到了
我觉得这档股票在长天局
今天稍微整理一下
还是有机会上来啦
甚至我认为有机会挑战今年高点
好 所以这两档虽然不能算低价
可是是地位界喔
地位界
所以我觉得大家也可以留意啦
那当然喔
当然我们来看一下比较低价的
低价 友达
对 因为我刚才看到
群创
那我觉得那个友达跟群创
其实都讲到一句成语什么成语腾龙换鸟有这样讲吗有有腾龙换鸟你去Google藤龙幻鸟而且我那个时候想说藤龙幻鸟到底是什么意思我们才输血浅嘛我们就赶快去查
他说把不好的鸟
把它给移开来
空间出来之后
再把好的鸟放进去
所以他是在做所谓的调整
那不是狸猫幻太子
对对对
也可以这样讲
换一个更好的
狸猫幻太子最近是有点争议
我说了什么
好 这一波其实友达有上来
所以形态上是比群创好
那现在刚好纠结在这里
我的看法是什么
我的看法是
他有联手附材顶元
MicroLED的CPU光学模组
另外就是说他跟康宁合作
开发大尺寸的那个玻璃基板
他的玻璃基板是510乘515
市场就开始联想
510跟515
这不就是台积电的规格吗
所以大家就联想说
是不是有進一步跟台積電合作的跡象
對對 就是510乘以515
那另外就是說
其實他一直在資產活化
群創也一直在資產活化
包含像新加坡廠87億
華雅廠197億
高雄廠63億
那其實華雅廠跟高雄廠的處分利益
都算出來
一個是一個是133億
一個是42.8
那新加坡廠
還在做一個所謂的試算
那當然對友達來講就是正面
對不對 正面
你不要因為黎貓換太子就緊張了
你幹嘛還再度強調
觀眾已經專心在看有達股價了
那我覺得這檔股票
因為它有什麼
它有CPO
然後又有所謂的FOPLP
就是玻璃基板部分
先進封裝部分
所以我覺得這檔股票
其實相當有機會
是
便宜嘛
那我覺得這檔股票
20幾塊而已
20幾塊
如果到時候上來的話
也是很有機會
那另外一檔股票
可能我們就來看一下
這檔軟軟的環雨
最近怎麼走得有點醜呢
對 也是被壓著
這個也是有點醜
但是如果我們就產業面來講
其實它營收是有上來
然後800GPD
它還是占全球第一
剛才我們回到友達的頂元
友達的頂元
就是要做這個800GPD
然後另外就是說
其實環宇
它是切入所謂連續波雷射
這個就是說
它希望它的那個什麼
它的那個版圖更加的擴大
而且很多家常客戶已經驗證了
所以是有機會了
另外就是他也算
一點點軍工概念股
F35的紅外線感
所以我覺得這檔股票
接近前波低點在這邊
要破底的機會不高
反正這邊大家也可以留意
那你也可以怎麼樣
你也可以等粗量勾上來
最好是法輪有買
再回軍線上
對 積極的你要分批買就分批買
然後如果你是保守
你就等形態完成勾上來
那另外就是說
接下來台積電在9月23號
有一個OIP的論壇
就在中秋連假前
對 所以OIP的論壇
其實在美國矽谷
一連串好幾場
那包含像所謂先進製程
先進封裝 矽光子
所以其實又回到這個問題
然後台積電也說
它明年的資本支出
會慢慢的逐漸增加
以目前看來
2奈米的產能開出來了
台積電目前3奈米加5奈米
佔它的營收超過60%
所以幾乎都是先進封裝了
先进制程
然后缺的包含像先进封装
这个大家也可以特别注意
那当然这个是设备材料
今天也不错啦
对 其实今天蛮多中小股是反应的
当然我们锁定还是要鸡油油
然后另外就是说
它的武器要多啦
就是它的那个产品要多方布局
然后成长动能能够延续能够强的
然后再来我们来看筹码
好 那这个就是加登最近大家蛮关注加登的其实最近加登还蛮强不過這個高點剛好是剛好是媒體爆出來台積電跟艾斯摩爾要合作
對 要把那個規格
由6吋升級到12吋
剛好這個高點就出來了
爆量沒鎖住的那一天
對 那當然這個可能有一些
有一些是剛好掌握訊息的人
或掌握所謂的短線價差的人賣的
所以這個是大量
那我的看法
我的看法是說
其實壓回來了啦
我覺得如果說對他來講
是實質受惠的話
量縮價穩嘛
那反而你要找他切入點
那另外除了所謂的
極紫外光的光照規格之外
他也切入了所謂
前開式晶圓傳送盒
先進封抓
所以我覺得他的武器也越來越多
所以這檔股票大概可以留意啦
那另外一檔就是
居土西家聯盟
但我必須講喔
很難
軍華就相對好一點
可是軍豪
就因為他一直在百元附近
大家覺得是中低價
可是他就是很軟弱
對 但是偶爾他還是會跳一下
好 對
我可以理解王伯找了一檔
可能比較輕的
對 因為我想很多設備股
場務股
很多股票都是高價股
是 都是高價股
那你說從那麼多高價股裡面
我們已經幫大家追蹤了
包含像所謂的那個加登
或者是其他的
那均華1000多塊
還有冬季的金貸也漲停
可是均豪今天在
他總是在聯盟中相對落後
感覺上就是
需要你送暖
男兒當自強好不好
給他一點
大家可以支持
其實他持有那個
均華是57%
對 所以應該照理來說
收益很高的
對 反而應該是
應該是有良性的互動
那當然他的領域就是聚焦先進封裝
晶圓再生跟特殊載板三大市場
然後他自己出來講了
下半年接單的金額
比上半年的要一倍
所以我觉得
我觉得其实如果没有表现的话
不妨在那边等他一下
然后他跟至胜君华冬结
是居土西家联盟
要联手抢商机
只是说 赵华讲的没有错
其实这档股票
有时候是比较怎么样
牛啊 慢啊
但是你的下源其实蛮好抓
例如说就100块附近
就是这个低点
对 那我觉得
我觉得你就先一段一段
我们就一段一段
其实最近回答
也是有點量縮價
我覺得是可以多給他一些注意
如果軍華開始動的時候
有時候軍豪也會跟著上來
是 而且前面還有130幾塊的點
還離得有點遠的
應該有空間
我們可以現在買
然後可以來笑他們說
我們買的比他們低嗎
是 不是
就是他上面應該
還是有一些上工空間
對
這邊非常謝謝王博
王博同樣情境推演
他覺得搞不好滑雪會包牌室
對不對
不升息就搭一個比較鷹派說法
升息後面又搭一個隔派說法
當然最怕的就是鷹加鷹
可是這個機率是稍微比較低一點點的
不妨我們回到產業面來做觀察
CPU當然因為前一陣子漲很多
可是現在剛好揮檔了
它完全符合明年的成長率會大幅放量
下個禮拜就有台積電的技術論壇
一定也會提到CPU
而設備股更不用說了
我們常常講接單都已經滿到2028年去了
所以明年的大成長也是值得期待的
這兩項產業王伯很有信心喔
好 今天非常謝謝三位來賓來到現場
雖然這兩天的量呢是比較縮下來的
但我們的來賓都不斷的強調
這個時候正是選股的好時機
正因為台股有強勁的基本面
只要等到鍋蓋打開
只要等到晚上連準會比較有確定的方向
資金活水進來的話
真的較大有可危喔
那也希望今天理財答案是有對於投資有幫助喔
明天再會了 掰掰
优优独播剧场——YoYo Television Series Exclusive